weil es gut etwas geht auch uhr herzlich
willkommen war mein video ja natürlich
hoffen das würde ich euch uns gut leute
ich weiß ja wie es schon mitbekommen
habt ich habe es ja schon in dem ein
oder anderen video mal erklärt
beziehungsweise angedeutet ich mache
jetzt schon bestimmt ungefähr drei jahre
wirklich aktiv youtube also müssen jetzt
fast drei jahre sein und ich versuche ja
echte mal so wie jede woche meine vier
videos zu machen manchmal schaffe ich es
manchmal nicht aber ich habe sowieso nie
hinbekommen
einen monat lang jeden tag ein video zu
machen und wir haben jetzt heute den
ersten dezember und ich habe im dezember
halt einfach zeit viele leute sind auf
youtube und das bietet sich an
und ja deswegen gibt es ab jetzt vom
ersten dezember bis zum 31 dezember
sogar an weiter gibt es im video also
ich hoffe ihr seid aktiv macht die
glocke an und ich habe mir dann auch so
etwas kleines überlegt damit ihr
vielleicht noch mehr bock habt euch die
videos anzuschauen natürlich kann man es
auch schon von anderen youtube an dass
meine verlosung gibt oder so aber ich
habe wirklich in meiner gesamten youtube
laufbahn auf youtube noch gar keine
verlosung gemacht und ja deswegen bin
ich jetzt mal los gefahren habe die
steine auf den tisch geknallt
ein spaß aber es tat echt bild wissen
dass das ich hoffe mich für mich ist so
leute gefahren jetzt erstmal zum saturn
und ich bin gespannt ob ich da das
bekommen was ich möchte
wir haben auch schon 20 nach sieben
deswegen müssen uns etwas bein weil die
geschäfte machen die und 20 uhr zu der
ich sehr gespannt wie viel geld ich
heute auf dem berg
49 minuten die wir noch haben und
besonders leid
läuft welche playstation nehmen weißt du
das schmalz ich finde schwarz cooler
die wenigen schwarzen natürlich noch ein
controller ist ja nur einer drin
wird so leute iphone ist bestellt also
ich habe jetzt hier ein space grau und
noch die ps4 auf jeden fall ein sehr
lustiges gefühl einfach mal einzukaufen
und zu wissen dass es nicht für mich ist
okay wir sind jetzt hier in der ersten
abteilung und schminke so leute wie
wurden der frau technik weil die
zugemacht haben wir gehen jetzt in zwei
jahren ein gutes wenn ihr noch aus
so leute fahrrad leider auch schon zu
bewahren etwas mit dran weil der herr da
kann man noch tiefer spielen muss dann
auf jeden fall fahren wir jetzt noch zum
hauptbahnhof weil da ist wohl noch offen
und morgen muss ich da noch ein paar
angekauft ich muss mir das nie verlegen
ich hatte an einen hobart noch gedacht
und man sehen wie es morgen 18 finde es
macht auf jeden fall richtig spaß
einfach einzukaufen
ob man sich für mich ist aber von der
trotzdem tolle sache
das hast du das schön ich habe jetzt
einen wunderschönen blog starb
was auch immer von ghd gekauft kostet
nur 260 euro und dann noch so viele
andere mac produkte für 250 euro 1 und
linke 70 jahren kostet oder so die haben
doch ein schaden oder das ist ein stück
weißt du ich zeige euch das will ich gar
kein großes geheimnis draus machen ich
wollte es mal die tüten von da hinten
und dann schauen wir uns das mal
zusammen mal also das heftigste kommt
auf jeden fall zum schluss deswegen
bleibt bis zum ende dran wenn der box
machen
wir ziehen jetzt hier aber nacheinander
einmal sachen raus also es bleibt
spannend so weiter also ich liege dafür
übrigens kein geld habe ich alles
bezahlt ich wollte ja noch nicht sagen
ich würde sagen das ganze zu schnell
schlapp hier haben wir erstmal eine ist
wie nennt sich das eine index
polaroidkamera mega cool weil meine
einige der ortsmarke haben wir hier ein
paket in sachen drin im wert von 80 euro
und wir haben hier noch ein echt also
wird niemals gedacht dass mir so teuer
sein kann
das hier sind vier produkt oder fünf
produkte von mac das ganze hat den wert
von 250 euro alltag für sobald ich hab
grad mädels fahrer voll davon deswegen
weil ich ja auch viele mädels haben habe
ich mal gespielt habe ich schon jetzt
gehen wir los den mädchen sachen wollen
die nächste lage und zwar habe ich es
hinbekommen
ich weiß nicht die meist feuchte sich
auskennen werden wahrscheinlich diesem
karton kennen ein wunder wunderschönes
paar neue gysi zum solches jetzt noch
hinstellen da links oft geklaut
und das gute ist es gibt nicht nur ein
paar davon ich habe ein bisschen rabatte
bekommen ob das zweite paar wir haben
ich will es aber ein bisschen spannend
machen und erst im video zeigen wo die
hieß es dann auch verlost werden welche
dies sind würde damit dem ja auch
wirklich glaubt dass sich die linse
nehmen wir es mal ganz kurz raus ich
zeige euch nur ganz kurz hier die lasche
kann man das sehen
hier sieht man die lasche und hier
vielleicht das schild mehr bericht noch
nicht zeigen
hier ist auch natürlich eine originale
quittung drin das ist wichtig auch nah
sind
ihr wollt ihr also wirklich spannend
halten der familie kaputt gemacht und
was ich kann aufgeholt ist eine action
cam eigentlich mehr cool und ich hatte
auch mal eine kuh pro mit letztens im
urlaub das macht er spaß das ist jetzt
zwar ok aber auch mega gute qualität
also für meine spannung für eine extrem
gewinnt und jetzt wollen wir die nächste
ladung und das sind wirklich die
krassesten sachen angemeldet
wir haben hier ein ich weiß gar nicht
die macht habe ich vorher noch nie
gehört aber sie soll besonders in sein
jd die platinum professional
lockenstabes wird es ist irgendwie ein
kletterer sind mit locken stark oder so
keine ahnung ist eine bombe qualität ich
kann euch das hier mal kurz zeigen
da bin ich mal gespannt welche
glückliche dame sich darüber freuen das
ok deutschland jetzt das glaube ich für
meine männlichen zuschauer als natürlich
gibt es auch mädchen die zocken aber ich
glaube das bezieht sich dann vielleicht
erst auf die jungs wir haben hier eine
wii playstation 4
aber habt ihr eigentlich nur museen oder
eine playstation 4 500 gb mit controller
ich weiß nicht ob da ein spiel bei ist
ich glaub nicht deutschland kommen jetzt
zum absoluten highlight meist das
gekauft habe hat mein herz wirklich
angefangen zu bluten weil es von echt
tief in den geldbeutel gehen und zwar
mein auto wir haben hier eine durch
hitze und dem fahrzeug jetzt
wahrscheinlich was ist denn in der
glashütte drin und neben irgendwelches
zeug das ich noch zu den ganzen sachen
dazu geschenkt bekommen haben haben wir
die haltet euch fest
ein brandneues 18 ich habe gerade mein
phone 7 und verlosen einfach schaut euch
dieses iphone 8 an space grau 64gb habe
ich noch so gerade bekommen laden war
das letzte highlight sicherlich wie wir
das stattfindet verlost jetzt alles in
diesem video
natürlich wird jetzt in diesem ersten
video schon mal was verlost ich will
allerdings nicht zuviel verlosen weil
sonst habe ich ja nichts mehr für den
restlichen dezember also man sollte sich
auf jeden fall ein bisschen steigern ich
will es nicht zuviel raushauen was ich
aber sagen kann zum beispiel jetzt vor
allem das iphone
egal wie weit weg wohnt der gewinner der
krieg dich nur das iphone sondern ich
komme mir persönlich vorbei gefahren und
bringen das iphone vor bei der
playstation vielleicht auch werden wir
sehen da kommen dann auch videos zu und
dann
dezember teilzunehmen ich finde es
natürlich blöd dir zu sagen ist nur für
meine abonnenten oder ihr müsst durch
abonnieren aber ihr müsst mich
abonnieren hört sich natürlich mal blöd
an aber ich meine es wäre blöd wenn
jemand irgendwas gewinnen denn ich bin
meine videos gucken und dann immer wenn
etwas verlost wird gibt dem video
einfach noch nach oben und schreiben
einfach irgendwas in die kommentare zum
beispiel ich will die playstation haben
eine playstation toll ist ihr könnt so
viele kommentare schreiben wie ihr wollt
und wie ihr bock drauf ab und lässt mit
ihren mal fleißig durch ich will eine
playstation gewinnen damit ich alex
pettyfer 18 richtig hochleben kann es
einfach klappen
ihr freut euch jetzt sicherlich womit
fangen wir heute also nicht sagen wir
fangen mit dem gleichen gewinn an
wir haben hier ein paket das sind 2 t
shirt ist leider schon zusammen
hier sind zwei t shirt pulli mütze das
ganze hat einen wert von ungefähr ab
sondern höre ich weiß nicht ganz genau
ich kack einfach so viele kommentare
dazu warum wir das haben wollen oder was
auch immer gibt nach oben und abonnieren
und ja mal sehen wer das gewinnt ich
werde es dann mit der zeit auch in
meinen videos gekommen sagen wir halt
gewonnen hat also dass das erste teil
war es für die verlosung bereit steht
also für magath spielt auf den dezember
ich habe bock und ich hoffe ihr schaut
euch auch mal das ein oder andere video
an und wir es dann möglicherweise schon
morgen wieder videos kommen jetzt immer
unter der woche um 15 uhr am wochenende
auch gerne mal um 10 uhr oder um 11 uhr
schon morgen ist also bitte abonnieren
glock hatte hier ja wir sehen uns morgen
hat seinen job
das hält mich und die kann noch als
dekoration
wunderschön